الليلة، تحدق شبه الجزيرة الكورية في
برميل
صراع كارثي يحذر من أحد
كبار العلماء النوويين الأمريكيين، أحد
مراقبي كوريا الشمالية منذ فترة طويلة،
اللذين يقولان إن كيم جونغ أون يرسل إشارات
في وسائل الإعلام الحكومية بأنه قد يكون مستعدًا
للاستفادة من الفوضى العالمية.
لاستغلال ما يعتبره ضعفًا وضعفًا
بين الولايات المتحدة والحلفاء المقربين
كوريا الجنوبية واليابان، إنهم يتحدثون
عن الحرب، ويتحدثون عن
الاستعدادات للحرب في بلادهم، ولذا
نحن قلقون جدًا لسنوات
مدير لوس ألاموس السابق سيج
كان لدى هيكر، الذي أطلق سراحه، إمكانية وصول لا مثيل لها إلى
البرنامج النووي السري للغاية لكوريا الشمالية، وهو يرى
أكثر من أي أمريكي تقريبًا
ما يراه الآن، كما يقول، وهو يعيد إلى الأذهان الفترة التي سبقت
الحرب الكورية الكارثية قبل أكثر من 70 عامًا، وهو
تحول مخيف في استراتيجية الزعيم كيم جونغ أون
أكثر بكثير
أعتقد أن الأمر مختلف هذه المرة عن قعقعة السلاح المعتادة، ربما يكون قد
قرر أه أن الوقت قد حان
لاتخاذ بعض الإجراءات بالفعل على مدار
الثلاثين عامًا الماضية، وكان هدف كوريا الشمالية هو
تطبيع العلاقات مع الولايات المتحدة، كما يقول هيكر، وقد
انتهى ذلك في عام 2019 عندما محادثات القمة في  لقد
انهارت فيتنام في هانوي، وانسحب الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب وكيم من البلاد مذلين ومثيرين للغضب، حيث كان
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي يركب قطاره الخاص المصفح
عائداً إلى بونغ يانغ خالي الوفاض،
وربما يتخلى عن الدبلوماسية الأميركية
ويتحول استراتيجياً نحو الصراع، وقد
يعتقد أن هناك بالفعل
بعض الأمر.  بطريقة ما يمكن للمرء أن يقول
ما هو الطريق إلى النصر الذي قد
يفكر فيه بشكل مختلف تمامًا عما هو
تفكيرنا التقليدي هو أن
ثقة كيم قد تتعزز من خلال
العلاقات الوثيقة مع الصين
وتعميق التحالف العسكري مع روسيا
وزير خارجية كوريا الشمالية تشيس
أثناء زيارته لموسكو هذا الأسبوع فقط،
وصف كوريا الجنوبية بأنها دولة معادية، يعد
هذا استفزازًا سياسيًا وليس
مجرد اختبار سياسي لكوريا الشمالية
لصاروخ جديد تفوق سرعته سرعة الصوت يحتمل أن يكون قادرًا على حمل رؤوس نووية،
مما يزيد من تنامي اهتمام كيم بآرسنال،
ويقول الخبراء إن آرسنال يشكل بالفعل
تهديدًا كبيرًا لكوريا الجنوبية واليابان.
غوام لديها عشرات الآلاف من القوات الأمريكية
في جميع أنحاء المنطقة إلى جانب
جميع حلفاء الولايات المتحدة بالإضافة إلى بعض
الصواريخ التي يعتقد أنها قادرة على
ضرب البر الرئيسي للولايات المتحدة. ويقول الخبراء إن كيم
لديه أيضًا رابع أكبر
جيش دائم في العالم يزيد عدد أفراده عن مليون جندي.
هذا ما يقوله هؤلاء المحللون إن
التهديد الموثوق به سوف يقوم به ريبلي سي إن إن